remember this back story involving flags
flags at colleges and the burning of
flags the back story started at
Hampshire College in western
Massachusetts which decided to lower
their flag to half-mast after Donald
Trump won to be sensitive towards the
way many people felt that in a way there
was a death of sorts as a result of
Donald Trump winning and when that
happened many veterans were very very
upset because flag code dictates that
you only lower a flag to half-mast when
someone has actually died when there is
an actual morning taking place after
that Donald Trump jumped on Twitter and
said you know we really need punishment
for people who are burning flags maybe a
year in jail maybe stripping citizenship
of course it turns out that burning the
flag is constitutionally protected that
stripping citizenship has been banned by
the Supreme Court as a punishment for
crimes that one might commit so we've
stepped back from that but the latest
news is that there are 54 House
Republicans that of co-sponsored
congressman Michael Turner's bill HR 6 4
3 3 which would strip federal funds from
higher education institutions that take
down their flag and the way this is
worded is quote to render in eligible
for federal funds any institution of
higher education that removes sensors
takes down prohibits or otherwise halts
display of a flag of the United States
now you might read that and say that's
insane how on earth would you possibly
enforce that how on earth would that
work well let's look at section 2 of the
proposed bill called in eligibility for
federal funds which says in general
federal funds may not be made available
to an institution of higher education uh
pursuant to an official policy of the
institution to prohibit the display of
the flag of the United States by the
institution removes sensors takes down
prohibits or otherwise halts display of
a flag of the United States the way this
is worded guys you would think well if a
college says we are banning flags from
our cam
this that would sort of be one thing and
by the way I would argue that
institutions of higher learning would
not be able to do that how do you say no
you're not allowed to wear an American
flag hat you're not allowed to wear an
American flag t-shirt or have an
American flag on your backpack that
would be insane and no sane Court would
uphold that but what the bill is saying
is merely the choice not to have a flag
on campus would make it so that funds
are stripped there's no requirement
whatsoever that a college is display
flags on campus yeah I think it's really
just a piece of red meat legislation so
they can go to their constituents and
say I did this big important thing yes
not actually out to solve the ills of
the country and this is a major waste of
taxpayer dollars Rachel when you think
about number one the fact that that this
would be incredibly difficult to enforce
if even legal if you think about the
reality that there's no requirement to
fly a flag on college campuses it talks
about just removing a flag and i was
looking at comments on conservative
forums about this and there were right
wingers saying good federally funded
institutions shouldn't be allowed to
disrespect the country by not flying the
flag actually they can this is the
federal government attempting to coerce
speech not displaying a flag is not the
type of speech that the federal
government can coerce well legally
there's nothing sacred about a flag no
there isn't and if you pass a law that
tells schools specifically you must
display a flag you're basically saying
it's okay for the government to dictate
the specifics of how schools can legally
express themselves this is actually a
limitation on speech by the government
and when we hear about this idea of the
government should be as small as
possible from conservatives unless it is
necessary to pass a law there should not
be a law passed only make laws when they
are absolutely necessary how can you
argue that this is even remotely
necessary Pat and it actually stands me
when conservatives are okay with big
government when they agree with it
usually in the name of patriotism and
otherwise it's hey uh not
non-intervention by the government yeah
and then it's such a big infringement on
their free speech when they want to fly
the federer the confederate flag
public buildings it's a complete
contradiction there is a group on the
right that generally understands why
this makes no sense and that is actually
libertarians and I don't often or
regularly agree with libertarians but
they're absolutely spot-on that this is
something that would be incredibly heavy
handed and arguably not even legal this
is sort of like a bill being passed that
says you only get federal funds if you
use a particular history textbook or you
only get federal funds if the Chancellor
makes a particular speech on the first
day of classes and the last thing on
this is that there are those who say
these schools are federally funded it's
like if the Department of State says
they aren't going to fly the american
flag no not at all a school is not a
federal entity merely because it
receives federal funding and there is
absolutely no equivalence whatsoever
this is absolutely shameful it's a waste
of money it's a waste of time and it is
as Pat said just a red meat dog whistle
for so-called patriotic Republicans I've
talked about how people of all ages but
particularly Millennials are owning cars
less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com slash david support our
show reduce your carbon emissions and
you're spending on cars sign up at join
zipcar dot-com slash david